which is centered around information
technology and in addition to do that
I've been spending about 25 well maybe
even longer now uh 25 plus years in the
project programming space so uh a lot of
the work that I do is helping large
organizations make shifts away from more
conventional traditional ways of working
and managing projects into more agile
more lean types of practices so there's
a a lot
of almost every company uh in the world
is actively looking for ways to become
more lean more efficient so really
excited to uh spend some time with
everyone here today talking about these
topics and as I mentioned um based here
in Houston Texas
Yahoo thank you for the introduction uh
so maybe let's start with getting to
know each other a little more better uh
but before that let me talk about the
agenda so we talking about obviously
getting to know more about you how we
can help you out better you know
understand this program uh while you
thinking of taking it up and also why
you should choose lean Six Sigma as a
career option and what does this program
offer exactly and how is this program
different from other uh programs or you
know options and uh what does make this
program effective and we also will be
sharing past Learners and their success
stories as well and uh we'll be taking
you through the enrollment steps and
we'll be having a special uh duration
for the Q&A part as well and while I'm
telling you this we already have gotten
a question in the Q&A box so that's
great uh so uh I just uh tell you a few
ground rules before we start so you can
always put down your questions on the
Q&A box uh in case you are putting that
on chat I am so sorry I I might miss it
because we get a lot of messages on chat
and I would love for your question to
get answered so please go and put down
your question in the Q&A box in case
you're not able to figure out where is
the a Q&A box just browse your screen
you will find a Q&A box there um and I
can see the introduction still coming in
in the chat that's great we have gotten
a great audience here uh and also this
session is being recorded so in case you
want a recording of This webinar you can
expect the recording over mail uh you'll
be getting a link of the recording and
also a bon bonus offer as well you know
of this program so awesome thank you
thank you please keep your introductions
coming and I'm pretty sure Brian is also
loving it seeing those introductions
so yeah uh as I said let's get to know a
little bit about you before we start so
you can see a poll on your screen so
please tell me like how much experience
do you have so if you have zero to two
years of experience you can select that
option if you have three to five years
of experience you can select the second
one if you have five to 10 years of
experience you can select the third one
if you have more than 10 years of
experience you can select the four
one awesome I can see the polls moving
in
uh folks who are still talking on chat
introducing themselves please do go and
vote for the poll as well because I
would love to know you know how much
years of experience do you have in order
to understand how exactly this program
will be helpful for you that is how
Brian can also help you out so I can see
the poll still moving in we have gotten
a great responsive audience here I must
say a very warm audience you know they
are very warm with introductions here
even welcoming everyone you know from
different different parts of the world
so I'll I'll keep up the poll for 20
more seconds so you folks have enough
time to go and vote uh you will see a
quick poll on your screen so how much
experience do you have you just have to
select an option and submit
it meanwhile I just read the
introductions on chat
s
okay the polls are still moving in so I
think few of the folks who have not
voted yet I would just to go and vote
now because I'll be closing the poll in
10 seconds so uh how much experience do
you have do you have zero to two years
of experience do you have 3 to five
years 5 to 10 years do you have more
than 10 years of experience I can see
someone replying on chat but I would
really it will be really helpful if you
go and vote on the poll
also awesome uh so I'll be closing the
poll in 5 seconds so 5 4 3 2
1 let me end the poll and share the
results so let's see Brian like what
kind of folks we have gotten
here uh it's surprising that we have
more than half of the folks you know
have more than 10 years of experience
that's great mhm and a few of the folks
have five to 10 years of experience few
of the folks have 0 to two years and 3
to five years experience thank you so
much for voting now let's start with the
program so we'll be talking about why
lean
Sigma so uh we'll be talking about lean
Sigma Six Sigma applies across all
Industries before that Brian for those
new to lean Six Sigma could you explain
how the principles of Lany Sigma apply
to various Industries such as G and
finance yeah that's a great question so
you know a few things just kind of get a
little more familiar and comfortable
with uh lean Six Sigma really is focused
on ways in which you can increase your
throughput so you know the amount of
work the amount of value you're
delivering and to get as predictable as
you can in order to kind of reduce the
amount of defects or issues that might
occur when you're creating something so
you can imagine almost every
organization is going to be interested
in finding ways to reduce waste right
waste is something that you know no one
wants to spend money on and it prevents
us from delivering the quality of of
products we want to and of course
finding ways to reduce defax is
something every organization wants to
understand right defax can not just cost
you money but if you you know sell
something that has a defect in it it can
affect your brand who knows it could
lead to you all sorts of issues so these
are things that are really important to
organization so lean Six Sigma is all
about how do we reduce waste how do we
get our processes very consistent
predictable and reliable so in
Industries like health care and finance
and Supply chains all those Industries
have lots and lots of information lots
of data that they're trying to
understand and leverage so lean Sigma is
a really important way in which we can
look at that information find ways to
get more efficient more effective and
then unlock all this additional value
and one of the things you're going to
hear a lot about as we talk about l
Sigma is this idea of demic which is
just an acronym that stands for divine
measure analyze improve and control so
this is a very wellestablished um set of
uh practices and processes that help
organizations continuously improve so
big part of this is we're always trying
to get better and whether that's just
making little improvements every day big
improvements through a large project or
initiative we're always trying to find
ways to kind of improve the work that
we're doing W that's
great uh can you also tell us like U
what are the range of career options uh
folks can I think I went to the wrong
slide okay so
sorry yeah so yeah I was talking about
what are the range of career options
that individuals can pursue in this
field and uh as also we can see the
salaries you know the salaries also
basically are pretty high in terms of
Lan Sigma right yeah yeah that's such a
great question Rasha you know obviously
if we're going to invest the time
learning these skills and techniques we
want to understand the return we're
going to get from it and a few things
this is clearly showing first off
there's lots of demand for these types
of skills so that role of a quality
manager or some kind of you know process
engineer Improvement efficiency um
expertise all of that organizations are
actively looking for you can see the the
some of the companies that are listen
the year these are you know very Marquee
companies companies recognized around
the globe Amazon Microsoft LinkedIn and
uh there's many others Amazon is
certainly leading the charge here but
don't forget Google and Facebook
companies were all very familiar with
they're all looking for these kind of
skills and as a result they're going to
compensate this very very attractively
so you can see you get a um a fair
amount of you know very look that
$116,000 a year wouldn't that be nice uh
to kind of rely on and have that coming
in to your bank account so uh and that's
because companies see the value of this
is a an area that they know that making
uh getting highly skilled people and
that can do this work is going to
actually translate into even bigger
savings uh for the organization so
that's a big reason we're seeing so much
interest in these
roles there's definitely plenty of
demand uh you know when it comes to L6
Sigma definitely agree with that and
also there are plenty of career options
as well which individuals can pursue
within this dynamic field um can you
take us through uh these career
options yeah what makes this a little
bit exciting as you pointed out is
you've got lots of paths you can uh
follow and and lots of levels you can
progress through so we can see the
starting point you just start as a
quality engineer you're getting close to
the solution you're kind of really
understanding how something's getting
made how something's getting distributed
and that's where we're going to learn
and techniques like lean managing lean
management is sort of mapping out the
process looking for place places where
we have waste a delay maybe re-entering
data from one system to the next you
know that's not actually adding values
so uh quality Engineers are looking for
ways to kind of improve the quality by
removing waste and they're going to use
techniques like mini tab which is a
statistical analytical tool and then
this lean Six Sigma Green Belt which is
a great way to demonstrate that you've
got proven skills that you've applied
and then you can showcase back to your
employer or maybe a potential employer
to demonstrate you really know what
you're doing but then quickly you see
kind of move up the ladder right you
become a quality manager that's when we
start introducing ideas like agile how
can we organize teams in a way that they
can deliver value effectively by
collaborating well together interacting
and then finally that program manager
level uh that's a place where suddenly
we introduce ideas like digital
Transformations how can we shift an
organization away from more manual types
of processes into digital ones that are
supported by software um so that's a a
big Focus for any organizations right
now because that allows them to even
unlock more
value uh wow that's great uh we we do
have a lot of career options here which
folks can take up uh now U so we have
talked about the basically you know the
salaries we have talked about the skills
needed uh so I'm pretty sure you here
because you are interested in the lean6
sigma program right right so what
exactly is stopping you is something we
will have to understand before we go
forward so uh you can see a quick poll
on your screen uh for folks who have not
not able to vote earlier so just to let
you know you will see a quick poll on
your screen all you need to do is you
can select multiple options here so uh
what exactly is stopping you from taking
this lean Six Sigma certification in
general so if you can't find a fully
comprehensive curriculum you can select
the first option if you feel like you
wouldn't get the practical exposure you
need to become a lean Six Sigma expert
you can select the second one and if you
feel like I find it really difficult to
learn from pre-recorded videos you can
select the third one if you feel like my
work schedule won't allow enough time
for learning so you can select the
fourth one you can select multiple
options as well uh this is just to
understand what exactly is stopping you
from taking this lean Six Sigma
certification before we move forward and
uh again I'm saying that we have gotten
a very responsive and attentive audience
here the polls are still moving most of
the folks have already voted for the
poll uh so this is a very quick poll to
understand what exactly is stopping you
so we can help you better uh when
talking about the program review of lean
6 Sigma from yumas Amhurst ISB School of
Management so
yeah I can see folks are still choosing
which one to vote for the polls are
still moving uh I'll be sharing the poll
results in sometime basically what
exactly is the biggest concern we'll be
talking about that as
well okay I'll be closing the poll in 10
seconds so few of the folks who have not
voted uh can go and select what exactly
is stopping you from taking the lean Six
Sigma certification what are the issues
basically what is the biggest concern uh
this for this poll you can select
multiple options and submit it only I
can see few folks have not voted I would
suggest just go and vote because I'll be
closing the poll in 10
seconds
yeah okay awesome five more seconds so
five 4 3
2 still moving
one okay I'll share the results okay so
we can see Brian the B biggest concern
here is I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become a lean Six
Sigma expert and uh the second one being
uh also the biggest concern that my work
schedule won't allow me enough time for
Learning and I can see some of them have
voted for I can't find a fully
comprehensive curriculum and a few of
them have voted that I find it difficult
to learn from pre-recorded videos so
thank you so much for sharing what
exactly is your biggest concern so uh
let's move on to more about the program
so the UMAS amus isba School of
Management program uh postgraduate
program in Le Sigma uh actually gives
you a comprehensive curriculum with an
industry aligned learning path uh you
also get to work on case studies
Hands-On projects and simulated test for
practical experience which we are going
to talk about a more moving further and
uh you get access to online live virtual
classrooms with peer and instructor and
interaction and also flexible to fit
your lifestyle and schedule so uh this
program duration is of 6 months and uh
you can just complete this by giving
five to 10 hours per week also uh we
have like few advantages in this program
uh this is powered by KPMG and the
content provider here is Harvard
Business publishing uh so uh this
program for yumas Amherst is an industry
learning path uh just one one question
like Brian what happens in the live
Learning Classroom do they experience
only like a live lecture or does it
offer more than that yeah that's a great
question and obviously some folks
pointed out that they just don't get as
much from watching pre-recorded videos
so I think one of the the more powerful
features of this uh uh program is the
fact that you will have access to online
live virtual sessions uh you'll have
interaction with instructors like me uh
to your point Rasha it's not just me
talking directly to the participants
we're actually engaging in conversations
so you have an opportunity to bring up
questions and say hey this is something
I'm dealing with in my organization and
and the projects or initiatives I'm
working with and we can use that as a
place to have some conversations about
how these techniques can help you so
it's U it's very interactive I think uh
people that join and you know one of the
interesting things I noticed as you
pointed out almost half the people here
have 10 years of experience and what
makes that really interesting is that
experience from your peers is going to
be really helpful because they're going
to bring that into the conversation
you're going to be learning sometimes as
much from your peers these colleagues
and as you pointed out great networking
opportunity right yeah and as well as
your instructors so um this this is a
great experience for folks it it really
Blends in so many different parts of
that learning experience and everyone
that leaves it always feels like they've
learned so much they can take forward
and apply well that's really amazing and
also like uh is it possible to complete
this program in six months with just
five to 10 hours per week yeah
absolutely the the course is the program
is designed to be completed in that
duration uh the 5 to 10 hours is is
what's recommended now I will say I took
my mbaa online while I was you know
growing my family and working in
different types of jobs uh of course at
a point in my career where you you're
putting a lot of energy and effort into
your work so um online learning is a
really great fit for that and one of the
things simply learns done a remarkable
job on
and this is the benefit of them being in
this space for so long is all their
their educational uh tools and products
are Geared for easy access you can
access on your laptop on your tablet on
your cell phone you have a lunch break
you can do some of your learning then if
it's the evening you put the kids down
dinner's finished this is a good time to
start do some learning so it really fits
into lifestyle for for many people at
this point in their career where they're
juggling work work and family uh this
sort of fits nicely into those
slots um wow that's great and uh why why
you you told me that you also took an
online course right during that 10 year
of your life so how did you reach to
that level of productivity in order to
you know like complete that goes as well
yeah so you know exactly right um it was
all online and it allowed you to kind of
do this when it was convenient of course
one of the things we're going to look at
a little bit later is the community
forums so some of your participants in
your cohort the group of people entering
the program at the same time are going
to be different parts of the world so
you might be asleep or one of your
colleagues is posting a question you can
wake up you can add to it your
instructor's going to join in so um so
really does fit very nicely your kind of
lifestyle and the time that you have
available to apply to your learning so
that 5 to 10 hours is not one steady
Block it's an hour here it's two hours
there it's 30 minutes maybe even 15
minutes across the course of a
week wow that's great uh also uh let's
talk about how what exactly this program
offered uh so the program benefits and
offering so you get a UMAS Mass prog
post graduate program certification also
with that you get 150 hours of Applied
learning from curriculum align from
PMP uh and other certifications you also
get to work on three Harvard case
studies 17 Hands-On projects and other
SIM exams as well uh you also get to
work on Capstone projects that in three
different domains uh you get to earn 122
pdus to maintain your uh CCR for PMI
related certifications uh you also get
access to master classes by faculty from
yumas MH isenberg and Senior Consultants
from kpg which we are going to talk
about a little more later and you get
the humas MERS alumni membership as well
uh that is really interesting because
while you're doing this uh course you
also basically create a network of fors
coming from diverse Industries uh and
you get to be a part of this alumni
membership even post the certification
as well that's pretty great and also
nine credits which are transferable to a
yumas mher is online
MBA also uh what exactly is the
advantage right like so we are going to
go towards the yumas MERS is Advantage
so uh here's a fascinating fact U like
did you know that the yumas mher
University was founded over a century
ago and then uh it got renowned as
isburg School of Management uh that
traces back its origin to uh 1947 isn't
that interesting Brian can you tell us
more about the yumas MERS is a good
Advantage yeah for sure um one of the
things about University of massachus Sam
HST is it's just a very well-recognized
institution and not just in the United
States but global so if you've got that
UMass amorist uh credential on your
resume and your LinkedIn profile it's
really going to stand out it's really
going to separate you uh from a lot of
other people that are working in the
same field and just as you pointed out I
mean the fact it's it's 130 years old
that really speaks to how effective and
successful it's been there's not many
organizations in fact I think one of the
statistics I saw is less than 1% of
organizations are able to last more than
100 years so the fact that UMass am is
at this point uh is is a real
demonstration of of how strong they are
how good they are so um and you know as
you pointed out too I think a really
important part of this it's you know
certainly it's important to have a
well-recognized institution on your
resume but perhaps as important more
important is the networking
opportunities you'll have a group of
other people that have had a similar set
of experiences and they're all going to
be similar points in their career and as
they progress upwards you're going to be
you know kind of connected with them
engaged with them learning with them
maybe find find Opportunities through
them wow that's great and also having
yumas Hast in your CV is basically a
prestigious and recognized worldwide so
that's also a good plus and we talked
about the KPMG Advantage so uh the KPMG
Advantage comes uh basically with a lot
of projects you can work on uh dedicated
mentoring real world case studies master
classes you will have an access to and
ask me anything sessions as well uh KNG
is one of the big four Consulting firms
with a presence in over 140 countries so
that's a really good advantage to have
as well uh how is this program different
from other programs uh so uh this
program basically gets your job ready
and uh basically with an industry
aligned curriculum and learning path uh
so uh we'll be talking more about that
Brian can you take us through step by
step how exactly this program helps you
build your skills and gets your job
ready yeah absolutely so we can see that
there's a couple of steps here we're
going to start the foundation really get
everyone comfortable with what lean
management really represents so learning
about the concepts how to kind of apply
them in real world settings looking for
ways in which we can streamline
processes to reduce waste so that's sort
of the first step then as we see we'll
kind of progress on from there we um not
sure if you can advance the the slide
for us here
Rasha uh just one second is it not
visible to you oh uh yeah I just see
step
one there we go yeah so the next one is
when we start introducing some of these
other U methodologies these agile
methodologies so um if you're not super
familiar with what agile really
represents uh it primarily focuses on
creating small high performing teams
that work in short time box iterations
or periods and then they incrementally
add work through each one of them so
you'll learn a lot about agile you'll
get an agile certification from uh the
the world renown project management
Institute and that's going to give you a
really good platform to take these ideas
and then work with teams so they can be
more effective and efficient and once
you've done that then we're going to
start weaving in some new Concepts
particular around statistical analysis
and we're going to use some tools like
mini tab and mini tab is a statistical
analysis uh product that's going to help
you take Lar sets of datas and look for
things like patterns and statistical
variations that might occur so you know
where to focus your lean practices and
expertise and once we've got you to that
point then we really opened up the door
to let you get your
certification as a lead Six Sigma Green
Belt so there's two levels Green Belt
then the black belt so we're going to
start with the green belt and then step
into the black belt so you're going to
leave with both of those certifications
which again very well recognized and
then we're going to talk about digital
Transformations how you can help
organizations that are all taking
advantage of the shift into digital
transformation now many of you probably
heard about you know chat GPT you know
that's all the excitement and the rage
these days well it's really focused on
artificial intelligence and machine
learning so organizations are taking
those ideas they're applying them into
their organizational structure they're
looking at their data so healthc care
Financial Services Supply Chain they
have huge reams of data and they want to
understand that how they that data is
can be used to be more effective more
efficient increaser throughput and
that's where actually a lot of this AI
machine learning is starting to come
into play so really exciting time
particularly if you're you just now
getting introduced to this space uh
because it's about to lift off you have
no idea the clients I'm working with
they're all heavily invested in that
whole digital transformation space now
we close things off with what's called a
Capstone project I know we're going to
talk a bit more about this later Rasha
uh but really the Capstone project is
just a way in which we bring all these
skills that you've learned through those
previous steps together and you can
showcase them in solving a real world
business challenge that you can use to
demonstrate to your current employer or
a future employer that you've got these
skills that they can leverage to bring
you into position and then we close it
off of course with your your certificate
of completion it's uh ready for framing
you can hang on the wall add it to
LinkedIn your resume and U and you're
done wow that's that's great uh I'm
actually looking forward to the you know
learning environment as well also we'll
be talking about the program outcomes uh
Brown uh will will you elaborate like
what participants can gain from this
program uh especially in terms of
combining lean practices and Six Sigma
techniques for process Improvement for
sure for sure for sure yeah one thing
just to kind of bring to your attention
the first off is um you're going to hear
a lot of different terms here like deic
and uh you know uh Six Sigma and you
know uh upper and lower control limits
all those but at the end of the day it's
very simple we're just trying to reduce
waste we're just trying to find ways in
which we can reduce inefficiencies and
the larger an organization is oftentimes
the more those efficiencies exist so we
are all about fighting those waste
measures finding ways in which we reduce
those reduce the number of defects that
occur so that's really what lean and Sig
Sigma is all about now how do we do that
well first off you know if we've got a
defect or we've got some waste we need
to go to the root Source what's the root
cause of that we need to solve those
problems so we're going to teach skills
and how you can analyze the root cause
of some of those defects and that waste
we're going to introduce um well
structured processes like deic that
Define measure analyze improve and
control it's going to show you how you
get to identify the root causes and what
you can do once you've identified them
we'll introduce some uh some projects
and how you can kind of Leverage your
experience in these projects and help
your own organization get better at
reducing waste um all sorts of different
techniques we're going to talk about
things like you know the five s's the
waste reduction techniques process
mapping really instrumental as well as
value stream mapping how is value
delivered to across your organization
mistak proofing we sometimes call that
Pooles which is sort of a Japanese term
talks about making something mistake
proof a person can't uh cause a defect
or an issue uh and then of course
statistical analysis this is the the
math part of the program don't be
intimidated though um I'm not really a
math expert and I was able to uh do it
all without too much difficulty but the
statistical analysis is a very valuable
tool that helps you identify where you
should be focusing your energy in
reducing waste and
defects wow that that's really amazing
and also uh like uh they get to master
in demand project management Frameworks
and tools in this program uh basically
can you explain about this project
management Frameworks and tools I'm
pretty sure there are many more than
this right like what we're seeing on the
slide this is a ton yeah and many more
at the bottom but on the left hand
column you see we've got deic we've got
agile we got that PMI which which is the
project management body of knowledge or
pinbo and we got lean 6 Sigma so those
are Frameworks those are ways in which
we are going to look for and solve
problems and understand how we're
progressing and those are really
valuable so we can organize teams and
programs and initiatives and on the
right hand side we're going to leverage
some tools so we talked a little bit
mini tabs statistical analysis tool but
other tools are jira jira is a Work
Management tool it's going to help
understand what work needs to get done
who's working on things how do we track
our progress we've got of course
Microsoft Office because we're going to
use Word and Excel and PowerPoint to
present our ideas and share that with
stakeholders and Leadership and then
finally we got Microsoft Project which
is a really indispensable tool to help
us organize our work and make sure we're
on track on schedule There's issues or
problems we know when they're occurring
so we can get them resolved so um what's
nice about this is you walk out of this
six-month uh program with skills in all
these areas and these are very highly
sought after skills that organizations
are looking
for wow that's
great uh so we we also have like uh
leading practitioners in this lean Six
Sigma program uh Matt Joseph who has 10
years of experience and has a Master in
Black Belt in lean 6 Sigma and chain
professional Supply in Supply management
and many more and we have Anita stalling
who has 17 years of experience and is
certified lean Sigma Black Belt with
Proficiency in QC QA Kapa and Le Sigma
management and many more and we also
have parul Chri here with us who has 14
years of experience in PMP PMI and
design thinking and much more and we
have global leaders as program advisers
Alan Robinson who is a professor and in
operations Management in University of
Massachusetts Amherst and Michelle B who
is a senior lecturer uh in is School of
Management so basically they make sure
that simply learn is delivering uh you
know as for the standards uh and also
what makes this program effective we are
going to talk about that uh so basically
this boot camp will help you learn the
right skills for today's top cloud
computing roles and uh the live sessions
will be delivered by Leading experts uh
you will get job ready training we we
are skill based learning and appli
learning via interactive HBS case
studies and projects cohard based Lear
learning with prer collaboration which
we have already talked about we'll be
talking about that more and obviously a
24/7 learning support as well you'll be
getting through this uh you also will be
getting an experience of immersive
learning a live classroom experience
learn from the global pratical and
experts and perfect your skills with
Hands-On
projects uh we also will be getting to
work on Harvard case studies and
projects which we have talked about
initially that this program will offer
you that uh Brian would love to know
that how does having a Howard case study
and a project or your resume boost your
uh basically job searching you know uh
process yeah great great question uh so
a few things you know if you're not
really familiar with Harvard case
studies of course these come from the
Harvard School of Business which is
probably the uh the preeminent uh School
of Business uh organization uh in the
world they publish a monthly paper the
Harvest Business review and in that are
case studies and now one of the things
that's really powerful with the harvi
case studies is first off they're very
real world they are talking about things
that are happening today uh in
organizations across the globe um the
second thing is they're written by
Leading leading experts these are folks
teaching these Concepts and ideas who
are working with some of the largest
organizations in the world to kind of
solve very difficult problems you can
see some of the examples here you know
Best Buy merging lean Six Sigma with
Innovation what an interesting challenge
right how do we find way which we can
blend this idea but being really
efficient and reducing waste with the
need at times to innovate which often
times when we're innovating we're
experimenting and sometimes experiments
don't always work out we're going to
have some waste that comes out of it so
there's some reasonable tensions there
how do we solve that so you can see
That's a classic example of a Harvard
case study it's it's challenging it's
thought provoking it's very contemporary
in real world and you can see the other
ones here fall into the same sort of U
uh flavor where we're kind of working
with well-recognized organizations and
looking at problems that they are
struggling with and then how can we take
these techniques to help solve those
problems so uh so this really prepares
you the whole thing you know we I can
talk theory all day long um but what
you're really interested is how do we
take the theory and apply it and these
are the case studies that we're going to
leverage to help you get uh better with
that W that's great and uh as we have
talked earlier that we also have a
Capstone project uh which basically they
can showcase to their future employers
that also uh acts as a advantage on a
resume when you are trying to search for
a job you're trying to get job ready as
well uh I'm pretty sure like maybe uh
folks who have not heard about Capstone
uh Brian can you tell us uh them more
about a Capstone project sure yeah so
that term Capstone itself sort of
implies it's it's the last stone that
you put on it's going to cap
what it is you've been building on and
in this case you know remember the steps
that we showed where we're learning lean
management and some of these agile
practices and the tooling Etc so we're
going to take all those skills and we're
going to leverage one of those real
world business scenarios and that come
from the Harvard Business Review Harvard
School management and we're going to
apply these techniques in a way that you
can showcase what you've learned now
here's what makes this I think really
effective the first off is it's not you
working in isolation you're partnering
with your instructors they are there
people like me who have a lot of Real
World Experience out in the field uh you
know 30 plus years working clients so
we'll be there to give you feedback
we'll be there to help you strengthen
this project so you can really showcase
all the skills you have so you're
learning as you're applying these skills
and you're going to be able to bring
that back to your employers or some new
uh potential employer to kind of show
that you really know how to do
this wow that's awesome and also we have
like multiple Capstone projects they
will be working on uh telling in
telecommunications domain and a
healthcare domain and four more uh so
yeah and and the end of it all uh you
will be getting a UMAS M house
postgraduate certificate we can which
you can see on the screen uh and you'll
be receiving nine credits transferable
to an online MBA with Asim School of
Management uh you'll be getting 1220 uh
pdus for maintaining your or a CCR with
PMI related certifications and you'll be
a part of Alumni Association membership
from UMAS murst University as well uh
you also will be getting uh you know
guidance on how to prepare for lean 6
Sigma Green Belt and black belt
certifications uh now let's talk about
the eligibility uh so you don't have to
come from a programming background you
can be from a non-programming background
uh you need to have a bachelor's degree
in any discipline and you need to have
at least 5 years of experience uh in any
work field uh Brian uh so folks who come
from a non programming background uh
have you seen the student succeed while
taking up this course yeah absolutely um
you know for for a few reasons first off
although um we will be doing some
statistical analysis and that does mean
you're going to rely on some light
programming techniques you know how do
you gather data or write some uh queries
against the data but you're going to
going to find that uh terribly uh
overwhelming if you don't have a a
programming background but again a lot
of what this program really emphasizes
is understanding how work is flowing and
identifying where there are um gaps or
Wast that are occurring so um a
non-program background is completely uh
reasonable and acceptable for this uh
domain and uh and if you do have to have
a little bit more of a aptitude around
programming mathematics uh well well
great you're you're probably going to
get uh get a lot from the time we're
spending in the statistical
analysis wow that's great uh also can
you take us through the learning
environment so folks can get an idea
exactly what happens you know when you
take up this course yeah yeah that's I
think a really U important question to
to kind of answer and show people so I
might need your help here rash you
probably just need to give me
permissions to present and then let me
uh let's take a look at the simp to
learn learning management system sure
sure I think uh will be able to share
your screen uh can you please try I'll
stop sharing okay yeah I think it just
says host disabled persistent screen
sharing so you might need to kind of
promote me yes yes can you try now can
you try now sure there we go wonderful
uh yeah let's uh let's take a look at
this together okay so we're not gonna
spend a lot of time with this but I want
to give you a little flavor of what your
experience is going to look like and one
of the things I just want to start out
with um what makes simple learn I think
one of the leaders in this space is
really their vision from the very start
of their organization was how do we make
this accessible and and really
userfriendly to our Learners so a couple
things I like about this is you're going
to log in uh this is the initial login
screen and you know you immediately
probably recognize that hey you know
what this isn't overwhelming we've got
these tiles and each tile represents a
different program okay now of course as
an instructor uh I tend to have a few
more here you might only have one so it
should be kind of easy to say Focus we
have our masters programs uh so let's
click on on one of these and uh again
very easy to access the content that
you're going to be learning from notice
a few things um when we look at um sort
of where we are this one is the UMass uh
uh graduate program project management
we can see that there's a a nice status
bar that shows where you are of course
I'm just starting here so at 0% of
learning but you'll be able to track
your progress visually as you're working
through the material notice we've got
three tabs here for courses electives
and certifications so the courses are
the core material that you're going to
be focusing on but the electives are
sort of those optional courses that you
can take you can take them all if you
want to and they're going to help
strengthen some of the skills and
learning that you're taking and of
course everything finishes off with your
CER ification but let's dig into a few
of these a little bit more so we've got
of course our welcome class uh one thing
to be aware of is when you join you're
part of a cohort you're going to join
with a number of other Learners at the
same time and you're all going to be
learning together so you're going to be
able to work with your your colleagues
you know you have a question or you've
got a way to help them or they can help
you you're going to have that
opportunity and then we're going to dig
into the courses themselves so let's
click on this first one what you're
going to see that all the courses are
the same same layout um you can see
we've got some self-learning here okay
so this is a great way to kind of learn
material as you're uh maybe taking a
break you're uh you've got uh some some
time of the weekend that you're able to
kind of get to your laptop or your
tablet this is all accessible through
any number of devices you can see that
they're all supported by videos uh so
it's it's very accessible you can see on
the right hand side we also have um sort
of our chapters so you can track your
progress you can also go back and uh re
review something that maybe you felt you
needed to spend a little bit more time
with you can see we've got clear
sections you creating high performance
team how do you start work do work keep
the team on track Etc now we also have
live classes so you can take this
particular course um independently kind
of self-learning and you can also join a
live class and the live class is going
to have a schedule you can click on that
and then find when uh these courses are
be offered you can join the live classes
you can uh you know if you've already
taken one you can still take another one
if you want to you know hear the
material again and then at the end we
have some assessments now this one's for
the project management
certification um which is one of the
certifications you can get the other one
is the agile certifications and what
simply learn has made available is some
practice assessments now mine's expired
right now but you can take this this
it's going to time you it's going to
track your results and it's going to
give you feedback on areas that you can
continue to improve on so this is a
great way to really understand have you
learned these Concepts so notice again
the the layout very intuitive very
friendly it's very device friendly you
can see this on your tablet on your cell
phone and you just kind of progress
through each one of these courses you
know here's the next one agile scrum
Master notice that again is the same
look and feel right so it's going to
feel quite familiar you're going to see
a a startup screen if I Advance forward
a little bit you're gonna see
the so there's high quality presentation
material that simply learn is develop um
very impactful you notice too that we've
got reference materials you can access
case studies uh the slides too if you
want to download these look at them up
offline you've got lots of great options
that can support your learning needs so
that's a little bit about what's called
a learning management system or LMS okay
and again we're not going to go too too
deep into it hopefully you're picking up
the flavor of what it does the other
thing I just want to bring to your
attention is something you mentioned
Rasha which is community so simply learn
has a very Vibrant Community that you
can join as part of your learning
experience and you'll notice we got
different areas here that you can uh
click on and uh won't spend again a lot
of time in each one of these this one I
don't think it's actually started yet uh
it's coming up shortly but you'll have a
place that you can post questions and
these are monitored by the instructors
and by simply learn facilitators so
you're always going a response your
colleagues and peers can be part of that
conversation and it's just a great way
to engage with the other members of your
cohort as well as with your instructor
so you might bring you know hey I saw
this in the news today what do you think
about this or uh hey this is a challenge
I'm experiencing in in my work
environment you know any ideas on how we
can work together on you know solving
some of these challenges so I I think
the communities is a really really
important part of the learning
experience and it's a it's a great place
for you to also be spending some time
outside of the learning management
system okay so Raj I think I think that
covers it was anything else you think we
need to cover uh no thank you for taking
us to the learning environment thank you
so much Brian uh let me share my screen
back
okay yes so we were talking about the
eligibility uh now moving on to the Past
Learners and their success
stories uh so uh the interesting part
here is that we uh get Learners from
excellent organizations and diverse
Industries as you can see that folks are
coming from it manufacturing bfsi
Healthcare software and others and
they're coming from companies like
Amazon vmw LinkedIn Microsoft IBM
Asen and I'll be taking you through the
enrollment steps as
well uh so the enrollment steps are very
easy uh the step one is you need to
submit an application to us at ask us at
simple.net uh and you your application
will be going for a review and once your
application is reviewed uh we will be
actually sending you an admission letter
and you'll be getting a call from a
learning consultant from San as well uh
the session starts uh on October 28 the
basically the current one which is the
upcoming one and the induction for this
will start on 9th of October uh we
usually take only 25 to 30 folks per
cohort in order to make sure that you're
getting all attention and uh we also
have like limited seats available per
cohort uh so if you're making a decision
to start it from 20th of October I would
suggest to take take it up now so uh and
also the for us candidates the price is
2,299 USD only and for Indian candidates
the price is
97,98 in including uh the GST uh also uh
folks who are joining from other
countries as well you can go and check
out uh this particular course uh as for
your country region and all and the
pricing will be almost the same so uh
yeah so tell us like are you interested
in enrolling in the program uh so you
can see a quick poll on your screen here
right now uh if you would are interested
if you're looking uh basically to go
into the lean Six Sigma career option I
would suggest that this is a really good
option to start with uh as Brian has
explained and you can see a quick poll
on your screen where you can see a yes
option where you would like to enroll in
this program uh and then basically the
upcoming cohort starts on 20th of
October yeah I can see the poll still
moving in and uh I can see folks
basically are really interested in
joining the program uh the interest is
coming as as yes um most of them so uh
I'll keep the polls on for few more
seconds while you're voting in so would
love to know your interest like are you
interested in enrolling in this lan6
Sigma
program okay I can still see the poll
moving uh so I will give you enough time
to go and vote for this one if you can
see a quick pull on your screen so yeah
think about it like would you like to
enroll in this program are you uh
thinking about this as a career option
so I would recommend to go and explore
it first because while you say yes here
you'll be getting a call from a learning
consultant from s who actually will be
taking you through this program as well
in much more detail I'm pretty sure you
have questions and uh while you're doing
this we actually are getting a lot of
questions in the Q&A throughout the
session and even now so we'll be taking
those questions as well uh while you're
voting so just after this poll quick
poll so I'll be closing the poll in 10
seconds I'll give you 10 seconds more as
the polls are still moving in few of the
folks who have not voted yet so are you
interested in aning this program so you
can select an option yes if you're not
you can select an option no on the quick
pull you can see on your
screen so I'll be closing the poll in 5
seconds and we will be taking the
questions from the Q&A box after
this so we have gotten a lot of
interesting questions from the Q&A
box okay so I'll be closing the poll
now okay I can see that more than 70% of
the folks actually are interested in the
program so we have gotten Learners who
actually are very curious about this
program and actually want to take it up
that's really great uh let's move on to
the Q&A part of this webinar so we have
gotten a lot of interesting questions so
let me uh start with a few of the
questions okay we have gotten a lot of
questions so uh I think the first one
being uh during the six-month program
how often would I be tested or how many
projects assignment would be required to
do Ryan can you help us with that
yeah so um there will be some
assignments of course and how many is
going to depend a little bit on which
one of the courses you're taking uh but
your instructor will give you a syllabus
that will explain to you what's expected
and uh the due dates so it's going to
feel a little bit like your college or
you know postsecondary education
experience um there will be tests
anytime there's a certification required
there is a test necessary these tests
are actually administered through
separate organizations so we have the
project management Institute that assess
their certification exams we got lean
Six Sigma organizations will support the
lean Sig Sigma exam so really depends on
those so those tests um I'll just be
kind of honest with you they're they're
pretty challenging these are hard exams
um but the whole intent of this program
what simply learn is a specialist in is
helping you pass hard exams so you're
going to get lots of support along the
way and uh I don't have the numbers off
the top of my head but U I know rasia I
mean generally speaking the the pass
rate is maybe not exactly 100% but very
close to 100% it's very very high wow
that's that's great I hope Ali that
answers your question uh let's move on
to the next one uh okay what certificate
do you get from this program is it
globally recognized uh so you get a U
Mass mher isber School of Management
certificate and it is globally
recognized uh we have already talked
about that okay I think I have asked you
this question is the five to 10 hours
per week just the weekly two sessions or
uh that's inclusive of some average
additional study time that would be
required with the two weekly sessions uh
yeah I think Brian can you help us with
this yeah I think that's that's accurate
it's the um it's inclusive of all the
the average additional study time so
it's not just taking the courses it's
what's expected for you to uh get
better with you know applying these uh
ideas and Concepts so includes you know
reading material um you know
answering the project assignments and
the case study so all that is in that
five to 10 hours a week I hope this
answer answers your question ali uh Ali
has one more question what happens if I
don't do well in a test or a project or
assignment yeah you know what I think
we're all a little concerned about that
at times um you know but but the
important part of this is you will have
access to a whole learning environment
here so people like myself simply learn
facilitators your peers we're all there
uh we're going to be available to to
help you succeed and what simply learn
puts is its highest priority is the
success of his students so when you need
help it's really just a question of
asking for help if you're struggling
with maybe some of the practice exams um
that's okay I had challenges with some
of the ones I wrote too so you just talk
to your your your instructor and you say
hey could you help explain these
Concepts a little bit more to me so I
can be successful in that
exam exactly we have a 247 learning
support available as well uh you can
always uh you know reach out to the
learning support as well I hope that
answers your question uh the next one is
by sakib uh I have done lean6 Sigma
Green Bel training and given test from
my company's e-learning platform do you
think I still need this program
uh well you know I think with s what I
might suggest is and by the way
congratulations it's great that you've
got that background um that's going to
be a great input because we are
absolutely going to take that and we're
going to expand it so you're going to
learn all sorts of other skills and
techniques that are going to complement
your current Six Sigma Green Belt uh
training and we're going to build on
that we're going to get you to Black
Belt as well as enhance it with some of
these other techniques and skills so um
yeah I I think there's lots of great
opportunity for you um in this program
with with that
background uh I hope that helps you Sak
uh I know Sak left like just a few
minutes back that he will see the
recording but he was here uh so um okay
I can see one question how can I go
about becoming a black
Bel yeah well this is what the program's
intended to do it's going to help you
understand how you get your black belts
simply learn will be there along with
the University of HST and we'll get you
ready to to take your your black Bel
certification uh now I will say you know
that the Black Belt certification is
going to require you to kind of put
together examples of work and there will
be some tests involved in that um but
it'll all be explained to you in the
program yeah I hope that answers your
question uh I can see um so must the
postgraduate program be taken in six
months or I can do it in a lesser
time well um we do want you to kind of
maintain Pace with the cohort so um you
know you'll probably need to take the
full six months these courses are going
to start at specific times we want you
to learn with the others in the program
um now you know whether that means you
can do a little faster spend a little
bit more time uh you know getting ahead
uh that that's a little bit up to you
but generally speaking we're going to
expect you to take the full six
months I hope that answers your question
I think someone in the chat has asked
like how long is this course and what is
the cost uh I think I've already shared
that but I'll just share it again so the
course is of six months duration and uh
the price for us candidates is
$2,299 USD I hope that helps uh okay
about the recording you'll be getting
the recording of the webinar post
webinar over email uh with a link to
view the recording in case you want to
go through it again so uh yeah that is
the answer uh so how much is the program
are there subsidies or sponsorship
opportunities or installment payment
plan available uh so yes so there is an
installment payment plan available uh
which you will be getting to know uh
from the learning consultant they will
take you through the financing options
available uh if you're joining basically
from the US side or India side or any
rest of the world so yeah I hope that
answers your
question I can see one question from
Tony the prerequisite of five years work
experience is just that five years of
work experience in general or five years
of worker experience in Six Sigma or
quality
management yeah the simple answer to
that is five years of work experience in
general if it happens to be in 67
quality management fantastic but it
doesn't need to
be I I hope that answers your question
toon me
uh
okay let me see we are getting a lot of
lot more questions right now
okay okay I I can see one question I see
some training and agile in PMP does the
course offer these certifications as
part of the learning
experience yes they do uh so you will
have an opportunity to kind of get your
PMP your uh ACP or agile certified
professional uh certification so you'll
have access to all those and um yeah
you'll have lots of new acronyms put at
the end of your name when you completed
the
program okay I can see bhat has asked
like I have only bcom degree is it
eligible to enroll in this particular
course oh uh sorry the bcom degree is
that the question yeah like oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah becom is a bachelor of
Commerce is a well recognized degree so
yeah that would absolutely be a eligible
to enroll in the program awesome I hope
that answers your
question I can see I did greenv training
years ago but did not do the exams do I
still need this training well um I think
if you did it years ago you're probably
going to get a lot from refreshing a
little bit and uh don't forget it's not
just that one topic around the uh link
to Sigma Green Belt it's also agile it's
some the tooling it's the digital
transformation so it's very enrich so
yes I would uh think you'd get quite a
bit of additional value from taking this
awesome if I hope that answers your
question okay uh is there any value in
auditing the
course bill has asked this question yeah
that's a great question I don't think
this is the type of course you would
generally need to audit audit basically
means you're going to take the course
but not take the exams um yeah that
that's a little bit more oriented for
more traditional University settings so
this one is uh little more geared to
people that just want to get the
certification learn the skills and apply
them so I'm not even sure we have an
audit option available uh but you really
would need it for this
one uh I hope that answers your question
Bill uh I can see one question what if
the six months duration is not
sufficient for a candidate is there any
way to extend it well that would be a
question you'd really have to take up
with your instructor and with a simp to
learn uh facility I know you know we
certainly aware that we all have you
know sometimes life happens right U we
might have some something we didn't
expect occur uh so we're very familiar
with that um we'll we'll absolutely work
with any any students that need some
additional help uh extending their their
time so it's just a question of having
that conversation bringing it up and
then working with us so we can set
something up for
you uh awesome I think we'll be taking
one last question uh what is required to
get certificate as black built after the
course is
completed sorry what
is I can see this one question on chat
here if in case you're looking I'll just
share it with you oh chat question okay
so what do we need to do to uh get the
certificate is that the question yeah so
what is required to get certified as
black belt after the courses comp oh got
it yes yeah so that again will be uh uh
explained um during the course what is
required there's usually a couple things
you got to demonstrate that you of
course know the skills through some kind
of test exam and then the other is that
you uh actually work up a project that
you can use to show that you can apply
these techniques so um that will all be
part of the program so you'll get a lot
of support doing
that awesome uh thank you so much Brian
for helping us with the queries from the
Learners which we have gotten here uh so
um I just have one more question uh how
soon are you planning to enroll in this
program so uh I'm pretty sure if you
have answered yes please go ahead with
immediately uh I would suggest because
the next cour starts in 20th of October
uh but I'm pretty sure like a lot of you
are thinking okay not immediately I am
interested in this program uh but I
still need a little more time so you can
select other three options within three
months if you're planning to start is a
good time to start because there's a
another cord coming up in uh December
and uh you can join that cohort as well
so if you're planning to start
immediately you can select the first
option so how soon do you plan to enroll
in this lean 6 Sigma program you can
just quickly submit your answer on a
poll you're seeing on your screen right
now and meanwhile you're doing that just
to let you know you have been a great
audience a very warm audience with lot
of introductions coming from different
different parts of the world and uh it's
it's great to have you here in this
webinar okay I see one more
question okay it's not related to L
Sigma sorry we can't take it uh today so
so
sorry okay I can see the poll still
moving in so a few of the folks who have
not voted yet uh so please go and vote
like how soon do you plan to enroll uh
so folks who have already selected yes
they are interested uh I would suggest
to go for the immediate program because
it actually is starting in some time so
it's starting like in on 20th of October
so there's still time for that uh if you
are still thinking about uh you know
like okay I need some more time uh then
you can select the within three months
option within six months option or more
than six mons from now if you still need
more time so please let us know that is
how we can you know help you out as well
so how soon do you cont so I'll be
keeping this poll uh for 10 more seconds
please go ahead and for that meanwhile
I'll be just checking the chat uh if we
have any more questions because you've
taken almost all the
questions awesome so uh I'll be closing
the poll in 10
seconds it's still
moving
okay few of the folks who have not voted
just go and vote like how soon do you
plan to
enroll
awesome I'll be closing the poll in five
five seconds 5 4 3 2
1 okay awesome uh I can see that most of
the folks want to join immediately or
within three months and few of the folks
are still thinking within six months or
six month from now so that's amazing so
uh thank you so much everyone for
joining thank you so much Brian for
taking us through this program uh and
thank you for answering all the queries
which you have gotten from the folks uh
I
yeah we'll be ending the session now and
we'll be seeing you in another session
with Brian soon thank you so much
everyone thanks Rasha thanks
everyone